[Music]
1923 to 1926
a bubble emerges the roaring 20s was
going pretty smoothly in america
electricity was becoming mainstream the
middle class was growing
radios cars factories were taking off
and the stock market was roaring higher
and higher without much volatility
investors made a nice 150 percent return
for the stock market from 1922 to 1927
with the hottest tech stocks at the time
leading the pack radio shack and general
motors
kind of similar to today success
prosperity wealth became the new normal
what of course i own some stocks what
sucker doesn't and what started out as a
legitimate stock market that was growing
due to real innovation new technology
and more productivity euphoric human
greed takes over and a bubble emerges
[Music]
and when a bubble forms and eventually
pops you want to know who suffers the
most
workers employees they have the least
amount of savings and they're the first
ones to get laid off
when a bubble crashes you want to know
who profits the most entrepreneurs those
who have a great business
sure they'll suffer a little but they'll
also be the ones with cash to take
advantage of the greatest sale of a
lifetime
that's where trends comes in the easiest
way for you to find your next big idea
with the trends membership you'll get
thousands of great business ideas and
trends you can capitalize on straight
into your inbox
every week their team of analysts put
together a private report with dozens of
ideas that can make you a million
dollars
as it has for others so you can build
your business stack some cash which is
what i'm doing right now
before the next potential market crash
your next business idea is just an email
away
stick to the end to learn more or stop
what you're doing right now pause the
video
and get your first week of transfer just
one dollar by going to trends.co
jake tran right now the link is on the
screen and in the video description
below
1927-1929 the bubble grows
in 1927 the federal reserve lowered
interest rates from 4 percent to 3.5
percent for some unrelated reason
and this would be the spark that set the
bubble in motion
see when interest rates go lower it
becomes easier for people and businesses
to borrow money
when interest rates are high there is
less borrowing because it's expensive
when interest rates are low borrowing
increases because it's cheaper
and when a person borrows money he takes
out a loan for a house
a car stocks a vacation he has more
money to spend
and when you spend money someone else
earns more money
every dollar you spend someone else
earns and every dollar you earn someone
else has spent
so when you spend more someone else
earns more
so since the money you spend becomes
another man's income
when you have more money to spend thanks
to a shiny new loan you got because of a
great low rate
the people you spend your money on also
get richer because when a borrower
receives credit he is able to
increase his spending this is because
one person's spending
is another person's income and the
richer that person gets the easier it is
for him to get a bigger load
the bigger loan he gets means the more
money he can spend and give to the next
guy
and that next guy can now qualify for an
even bigger loan
and this whole process continues and
propagates throughout the entire country
until the whole economy is booming so
back to 1927 when the federal reserve
lowered interest rates from 4
to 3.5 percent everyone started
borrowing money to buy stocks
i.e trading on margin that newly created
credit made stocks go higher
which encouraged more people to borrow
more money to do the same
and from 1927 to 1930 just three years
stock prices more than doubled what
people didn't pay attention to was that
the debt to buy those stocks also
tripled at the exact same time
with many stocks trading at 30 times
their earnings
similar to 2008 and today was stocks
trading at 39 times their earnings
[Music]
all this growth attracted new investors
that were never really into investing
before
kind of like today wall street invented
new financial
instruments to borrow even more money to
make even higher returns
like things called call loans and
investment trusts as they always do like
in 2008
we call them synthetic cdos what is
synthetic cdo's
synthetic that is [ __ ] crazy since
they're new there's no laws regulating
them
they operate outside the regulated
banking system also known as the shadow
banking system
and since the fed only ever cares about
how much inflation there is for everyday
goods like food clothes etc
those things weren't going up stocks
were we're fine everything is going
amazing
and this is how bubbles usually form not
from rising inflation where the cost of
everyday goods explodes
but an explosion in real estate stocks
assets fueled by people borrowing money
thinking that it's only going to go
up stocks continue to only go up just
like today
and the higher they went the more the
speculators bet that they would rise
even more
the lower the lending centers got to
borrow money to invest because the
lenders were making money hand over fist
this is a new age of prosperity stocks
are never going to go down why stop now
kind of like in 2008 don't have income
you get a mortgage
and since prices were so high the banks
looked like they were in good shape
unless prices go down and people start
withdrawing their money which is never
gonna happen
or in other words the herd was moving in
the same greedy direction
while at the same time the wealth gap in
america continued to grow
eventually to the highest point it's
ever been until today
and by 1928 the fed was finally starting
to see how troubling all the speculative
debt was
so they raised interest rates from the
3.5 percent that set the bubble in
motion
to 5 which would set the next stage of
the cycle in motion
late 1929 the bubble pops
march 1929 the feds started holding
daily secret meetings but didn't tell
the public what the meetings were about
this sparked rumors that the fed was
going to crack down on all this
borrowing for stocks
august 1929 the fed raises rates again
from 5
to 6 percent and just like how the fed
lowering rates made people borrow more
which cascaded into the market soaring
the fed raising rates had the exact
opposite effect
since people weren't borrowing to buy
stocks as much with the new higher
interest rate
no new money came into the market which
made the stock market not grow as much
since people aren't seeing the crazy
returns they're used to they start to
get nervous and pull their money out and
stocks start going down
since people aren't taking out loans
they have less money to spend and since
the money you spend is another man's
income and you're spending less
the next guy's income goes down since
that next guy's income goes down
he has less money to spend on the next
guy and the bubble feeds on itself
downward until it pops
october 19 1929 the stock market crashes
trading volume explodes bankers try to
stop the fall in less than two hours
nearly 10 billion dollars invested in
stocks
was simply wiped out black thursday
turns into black monday which turns into
black tuesday
and the economy starts to fall off a
cliff
1930-1932 depression
by new year's day of 1930 the stock
market crashed around 50
many thought that the wars was over but
the damage to the economy had already
been done
since the banks that lent out all this
money to trade were hurt particularly
bad by the stock market crash
even legitimate businesses that needed
legitimate loans couldn't get them since
the banks were getting squeezed
like how the railroad industry couldn't
get loans even though they were
qualified
the railroads were deemed systematically
important by the government like the
auto industry in 2008's
one of the first decisions that i made
as president was to save
the us auto industry from collapse and
like how in 2008
investors that were ready with cash in
hand to take advantage of this cheap
real estate that had more than enough
money to pay back new loans couldn't get
them
protectionism and anti-immigration was
on the rise as it usually is during
rough times like these
after all we can't let immigrants take
our jobs when there's not enough for us
they took our
people knew that the banks were in
trouble which led to runs on banks
and since banks only keep a portion of
the money you deposit on hand
as everyone tries to withdraw their
money the banks couldn't keep up
so banks started failing left and right
with nearly a thousand banks failing in
1930 alone
watch our video on the business of
banking to learn more
december 11th the biggest bank in the
u.s bank of the united states with
around 400
000 depositors closed its doors the bank
experienced a run the day before that
started from a false rumor
needless to say if you saw your life
savings disappear overnight
it probably wouldn't inspire much
confidence in the nation's banking
system
if the biggest bank can go down then no
one must be safe
at the same time 6 million people are
out of a job in the us
the bubble bursting has spread across
the globe combine that with the highest
wealth gap ever at the time
unemployment and overall suffering and
populism nationalism militarism and
extremist leaders have the perfect
breeding ground to take power
like in germany would you know who and
with japan invading manchura
that vicious cycle downward continues
and as money and credit contracts
the economy starts to really fall off a
cliff
1932 the show continues congress passes
the 1932 banking act
allowing the federal reserve to print
money 75 years later we would call this
quantitative easing
along with even more powers and social
unrest and conflict continued to rise in
the us and around the world
in the u.s wages were cut a drought
further ruined farmers
unemployment exploded to 25 and strikes
and protests were on the rise
in germany you know who sees his power
and japan invades shanghai
sowing the seeds for world war ii and
the psycho will continue all the way
until things started to recover around
1938
and in 1939 world war ii starts
all because you had to borrow money
recklessly
2009 the bubble forms after the crash of
2008
the fed lowered interest rates down to
near zero percent
just like how the fed lowering rates in
the early 1920s allowed people to borrow
more
and to spend more which made incomes go
up and the overall economy spiral up
that's what they were intentionally
trying to do here not to cause another
bubble but to just stimulate the economy
and stimulate they did the reason it
only went down 50
and and bounced back relatively quickly
was because the fed
came charging in uh to the rescue that
near zero percent interest rate
basically like steroids for the economy
continued for nearly six
years the economy was finally recovering
from the great recession we can't be the
ones to stop it now
it would be political suicide and the
result the stock market and housing
markets biggest
rise ever
kind of like the 1920s and 2008 and at
the same time a new world power was on
the silent rise
china by 2016 trump takes office
and has the fed slowly start raising
interest rates the same tightening that
caused the crash in 1929.
by the start of 2020 the market was
reaching a boiling point after 131
months of expansion
and then boom covet hits and the market
tanks by 25
now all things considered one might
think the market should have probably
felt a lot more than that
but remember the fed got the power to
print money during the great depression
and being that when you give someone
power they typically don't like to give
it back
ever since then the fed's power and
influence has only gotten bigger
we print it digitally so we you know we
as a central bank
we have the ability to create money uh
digitally
and the printing that happened after
2008 was just rehearsal time for
america's money printer
the entire country was bailed out
interest rates were lowered to near zero
percent again
after a tiny pause and by the start of
2021 over 40 percent of all us dollars
were printed in just the last 12 months
watch our video on why we haven't seen
hyperinflation to learn more with the
link below
the stock market quickly recovers the
housing market was never really hurt and
both continued their greatest climb
ever and the great recession 2.0 was
quickly averted
kinda like how the bursting of the
dot-com bubble in the early 2000s was
going to lead to a recession but the fed
also lowered race to near zero percent
back then
which delayed the pain eventually
building up to the 2008 crash
and this wasn't a crash in 2020 we did
not have a market crash
but 2020 was such a bad year to erupt no
no no people got unemployment benefits
people got
stimulus checks centered and people got
billed people got bailed out in so many
different ways where people didn't even
want to get a job because they were
making more money staying home than
getting a job
and just like how after the crash in
1929 most people thought the worst was
over
most people also think the worst is over
but just like back then
the damage has already been done
if you go back to before the covet what
you see is we have lost
considerable strength in the economy we
have fewer people working
and we have a reduced stream of goods
and services
and yet the price is much higher but is
it really justified that we have
delivered a serious wound
to the global economy and the global
stock market
has gone way up it doesn't feel right
i think we all know that today the money
printer is working at full blast with
more stimulus checks apparently coming
another 14 hundred dollars will be
coming i believe that it should go to
people who in fact are in need
the sad truth of a lot of the quote
stimulus
is it didn't increase much in the way of
of real production
but it flowed a lot of it eventually
into the market one way or the other
stocks are trading at insane levels and
an average of 40 times their earnings
just like in the 20s 2000 and 2008 to
give you some context stocks usually
average around 16 times
earnings the amount of debt people have
to finance all this growth is high again
just like in the 20s and 2008
and we have plenty of new financial
instruments except this time some of the
instruments were created by tech
enthusiasts instead of wall street
like bitcoin and robin hood that gives
new investors the easiest access to
margin trading the cause of the roaring
20s than ever before
now to be clear i am a big fan of this
tech but to think that there's no chance
of unintended consequences from this
decentralization is the exact kind of
thinking that led to the bubbles of the
past
wall street is also frothing at the
mouth over another shiny new financial
instrument
specs a new very profitable way to take
companies public
so spax have always been the scummiest
thing anyone can ever do in wall street
there is absolutely nothing that's a
bigger scam period in the history of
wall street and everybody on wall street
knows it a spac is simply
a convoluted way of saying that hey
we're going to take a company public
without
going through any of the the regulatory
scrutiny that the company needs to go
through when they're going public
which in the first three months of 2021
alone there have been nearly half as
many
spacks as the entire year of 2020 check
out this clip about specs on our second
channel to get a different take on them
and i wouldn't be surprised if wall
street has other new financial
instruments that we haven't heard about
until it's already too late
like in 2008 and then there are the
rather startling signs that we haven't
seen since the 1930s
number one the rise of populism at no
point in history have we seen a larger
wealth gap income gap
and political polarization than right
now and in the thirties
the top one tenth of one percent of the
population's
income is equal about to the bottom
ninety percent combined
so that type of magnitude of gap
has not existed since the 30s
this is reflecting the political
polarity that
exists and you could see that that's um
the highest since about the 10th century
now all i'm just saying is
there's a lot of political polarity
that's dealing with that
now it doesn't matter if you think this
is okay or not what does matter is the
resentment and social unrest that rises
out of that
number two how we're already at near
zero percent interest rates
if things take another downturn rates
are already near zero percent so the fed
won't be able to lower rates any lower
in a recession lowering interest rates
works to stimulate
borrowing however in a deleveraging
lowering interest rates doesn't work
because
interest rates are already low and soon
hit zero percent
so the stimulation ends so they're gonna
turn to printing money stimulus checks
welfare programs as governments have
always done in times like these
number three the rise of china to
challenge the existing power of the us
the last 16 times a rising power
confronted a ruling power
war broke out also known as thucydides
trap
just like the world after the 30s the
last time
those things happened were in the 1930s
and if you look at history going back
over periods of time before that
hundreds of years i made a point of
studying last 500 years
you could see these patterns in history
those are the circumstances that we're
facing
and so the issue really i think
is can we face those things in a
skillful way and a bipartisan way
so that we don't do ourselves
uh even more harm than the circumstances
have brought us as a challenge
full video on this in the future
subscribe so you don't miss out
but perhaps the most important sign when
average
normies for lack of a better term that
have never ever shown an ounce of
interest in investing
start getting into an investment there's
probably a bubble
why because normies that don't know any
better are usually the last ones to get
in
on an investment before it's too late we
saw it happen with the housing bubble we
saw it happen with bitcoin in 2017
and again with gamestop and this general
feeling of everyone thinking things are
only going to go up from here is kind of
what's in the air right now
as warren buffett says when people are
greedy it's time to be fearful
[Music]
i for one cannot wait for the next
market crash there is going to be so
much wealth to be made everything is
going to be on sale and my time
will finally come now you may be saying
to yourself but jake that's cruel
people are gonna get hurt how can you be
so heartless
everyone on this planet has the same
access to the same knowledge to prepare
themselves right now
many won't is that my fault it's gonna
happen anyways would it be more moral to
not take advantage of it to not make
sure your family is taken care of
when you know full well what's coming
just because others didn't prepare
i think that that has tantamount to
intellectual fraud
just to be clear i have no idea if this
is actually gonna happen
but the philosophy i follow in life is
that being that we can't predict the
future
you should make sure you come out on top
no matter what the future holds
so in closing i'll leave you with this
history never repeats itself
but man always does
[Music]
and it's correct that history doesn't
necessarily repeat itself
but the cause affect relationships are
the important things to understand
and they are analogous say covet never
happened there is no chronovirus
nothing happened and 2020 goes the way
it did
how does the market go where does it go
35 000 40 000
that's still a bubble that's been going
for 11 years no
economy expansion goes for 11 years and
the debt of the country keeps rising the
way it's rising for us
and the interest rates that's not
sustainable eventually
there is a crash that's going to come
and it's
not going to be pretty almost everything
happens over and over again for the same
reasons
okay so these debt crisis all happen
over and over again for the same reasons
they get it overdone and even if you
understand
it and the cycles well you can benefit
from those cycles
rather than to be hurt by those cycles
because and if you want to be ready for
the next market crash
the time to start preparing is now that
is where trends comes in
with trends you can discover emerging
industries before you hear about them on
the wall street journal
like this signal on the lucrative and
not capital intensive business of review
sites
like how the site best reviews recently
sold for 160 million dollars
or this signal on how the explosion of
religious apps is finally capturing the
attention of venture capitalists
and how being that 80 of america
identifies as religious
there could be a lot more vc money that
you can take advantage of coming in soon
market crashes are where millionaires
and billionaires are minted
it's when generational wealth is made
but only if you position yourself
in a way where you don't just survive
the next big crash but also thrive
that means having plenty of cash to take
advantage of this once in a lifetime
sale
and the only way you're gonna stack cash
quickly is with a great business
the clock is ticking discover your next
big idea by starting your one week trial
of trends for the grand sum of just one
dollar by going to trends.co slash jake
tran
the link is on the screen and in the
video description below
[Music]
new microphone let me know how it sounds
as i get a dialed in
and a new backdrop of my favorite
painting of all time
more details on what it is and why on my
instagram coming soon at jaketrend.io
don't miss out
do you think a crash is coming let me
know in the comments below i obviously
lean towards the side of yes there is
probably a market crash coming
although again i'm not going to say with
certainty i just want to make sure
that i come out on top whichever way the
world goes this video was based on the
book the big debt crisis by ray dalio
one of the richest people in the world
and the founder of the world's largest
hedge fund
an incredible read that does require
some basic knowledge of like the federal
reserve some basic economics that kind
of thing
and it requires you to watch his free
online uh video on youtube called how
the
economic machine works which is also an
incredible video
i will link the book below but if i were
in your shoes even though i am not some
kind of financial advisor or economic
advisor of any kind so you definitely
shouldn't listen to what i say but if i
were in your shoes
i would watch that free video by ray
dalio first and then i would focus on
building your career your income your
savings first so you have something to
stand
on and then once that is more in place
then you can go into the finer details
of a book like this to learn like the
nuances and how to really profit from it
and like timing and everything that is
my advice
if you are new to this channel we make
video essays just like this one every
single week on the most provocative
stuff in the world of business
for free so you might also subscribe
because there's nothing to lose and you
can always dislike unsubscribe leave me
your best hate comments
below so you have nothing to lose that
is gonna wrap it up for this video thank
you so much for watching you've been
awesome i've been jake stay dangerous
out there and i will see you guys in the
next one
[Music]
you